they have reached their final stage this
is literally of this era that they're in
right now
this is their final stage in saying
race racism race is the problem race
black people race race race systematic
racism that's why you're not successful
elect us we will help you so this is
kind of the final stage of this
and if it wasn't then there wouldn't be
so many voices like like mine
like like our friend candace owens like
so many other black voices iona presley
though
our voices are still black voices and
there's so many of those voices that are
saying
wait a minute this stuff isn't
necessarily true
let's talk about race because nobody
else is talking about race let's talk
about races
there's uh there's a lot of weird stuff
going on about race
suddenly america is the most evil racist
nation in the history of the world
you've got
peop you know the the whole i would say
democratic machine is running on the
idea that trump has
has just proliferated racism but also
the system was deeply racist before him
which is quite a condemnation of uh
biden and schumer and pelosi and
everybody else that's been around
forever
what do you feel is the temperature
right now just in
in a broad sense i mean i i feel like
honestly the temperature when
there are two different worlds here
right there are so there's our social
media world
um in the social media world on twitter
and facebook and instagram and
everywhere else is constantly at each
other's throats there's all this
division there's all this
because the powers that be particularly
on the left right now they they want
that division they think that
um ginning up that stuff is going to
push them back
into power but there's also the real
world as well
and and i think and maybe this is just
my
unabashed uh optimism for america but i
think that
there's a conversation that is happening
in the real world that is nowhere near
as as elevated and heightened as the
conversation of social media but
look i i think that what you have going
on right now is
the democrats in the left they have
reached their final stage
this is literally of this era that
they're in right now
this is their final stage in saying
race racism race is the problem race
black people race race race systematic
racism that's why you're not successful
elect us we will help you so this is
kind of the final
stage of this and if it wasn't then
there wouldn't be so many voices like
like mine like like our friend candace
owens like so many other
black voices iona presley though our
voices are still black voices
and there's so many of those voices that
are saying wait a minute
this stuff isn't necessarily true and
that gives me hope that there can be a
more elevated conversation but let me
tell you
i hope and i truly do pray
that they lose in november not because i
am praying
so much for the republicans and and the
president is going to save our republic
although there's a big part of that
but they have to realize that this is
not the way
for power this is not the way for votes
and i think that they have to get
shellacked a couple of times to really
figure it out and there's going to be a
lot of collateral damage
in the form of the the minds of some of
the young african-americans that they
are literally
destroying by selling this message that
racism is the number one problem in
their life
in order to get vote for democrats it's
destructive
it's insidious and i think that people
are starting to wake up to it
i like the way you describe that because
it does feel like we're sort of getting
if this is a video game we're getting to
the big boss we're getting to the final
boss where for
for eight levels they've just ramped up
the racism racism homophobia blah blah
blah
and now we're there like this election
is it and and it almost seems to me
that all they've got to run on is that
america is racist and if they don't have
that
it's like i don't think anyone buys any
of the policies and
unfortunately just the way the media
operates right now this isn't going to
be an election about policy this is an
election about basically
racism and socialism versus capitalism
and
and freedom something like that yeah you
know it is and and dave the thing that
always strikes me because i
i watch some of the left-leaning stuff
and and god i see this
you know never-ending clown car of of
the black liberals that come up and then
they talk about stuff so case in point
um so the mccloskey situation where
where this couple was defending
themselves from from
an angry mob who had by the way broken
into private property
and on the left with with the black
pundits this somehow becomes about race
and this somehow becomes the idea of
these people um
inflicting their white supremacy on
these black protesters um number one
those those protesters are not peaceful
number two they were not all black
and number three the last time i checked
the second amendment and the right to
bear arms is for everybody
it's not just for for white people so
i'm struck when i see these
conversations how
how quickly and how easily they remove
all agency from black people in america
and from african americans
in general they all of our agency is
removed
in these conversations yeah well it's
also incredible because they try to
paint the mccloskeys as evil for
defending their property as we
as we're watching all this stuff burned
down but it's not like the mccloskeys
woke up that morning and we're like
we're gonna go shoot people
they they had those guns for a long time
it sounds like they were actually
democratic donors at least at one point
and
supported black lives matter it's not
like they were just sitting there
waiting
to start some stuff it literally showed
up at their door
and then they defended themselves so
that's actually a good transition to
to media because you're uh you're a
media what can i call you assassin
i suppose as well you've just had it
with the with the mainstream media too
because this is the stuff they're
endlessly pedaling right
well it is and and a lot of people don't
realize dave that um so i went to
columbia journalism school i got my
master's group columbia i worked in in
medium production
for years before i decided to come out
and and say what i really thought and do
all this for myself
so i know all the games dude i know
about
trapping a tweet and leaving half of the
code off
um i i know what fake news is because
sometimes fake news are actually most of
the time
fake news isn't an outright lie but more
a half
truth and and so you see past all these
games when i first came out as
conservative i one of the first friends
that i lost
um got deeply offended when i told him
and not in a condescending way at all
told him that i've been working in this
at that point for about five to six
years and i know these games
and you're not media literate enough to
see this and he got deeply offended by
it and then that was it and
just like it's whatever um but people
didn't realize these games and i think
the deeper we get into this we see it
over and over and over again and
folks like like you and i when there
is an outright lie and i mean a whopper
it has to be shut down so quick
because if you don't then it becomes
part of the lexicon and it becomes
common
knowledge case in point of trump
very fine people comment which has been
debunked
so many times but it is canon
among the left and that's because and
that was a feeling on the right
because they didn't shut that down
immediately immediately when they shut
up
you know what's interesting about that
one is that uh for people that don't
know
a minute not even a minute 30 seconds
before trump said very fine people on
both sides he absolutely condemned the
neo-nazis and the white supremacists
but what's really amazing about it is
that biden when he launched his campaign
that's the video he used the very fine
people and he's talking about america
being racist and everything else and he
knows he can get away with it
because nobody in the media is going to
do anything about it and then yeah
us on twitter we'll hit back but he
knows uh cnn and msnbc and everybody
else going to run cover for him
of course they knew and and honestly he
knew it when he played the video
they they look at a certain point and i
think that media bashing is definitely
it's a fun pastime that that a lot of us
like to do on the right
um but at a certain point you can fool
some of the people some of the time but
you
cannot fool all the people all the time
and what is going to happen on the left
is
is people are going to start asking
questions they're going to start asking
bad questions they're going to start
asking questions that they shouldn't
have asked before
and then they will be excommunicated
just like you were
just as i was and and so i think and
you have been way at the forefront of
this because you saw
all of this stuff coming for a long time
before the rest of us
and so then the same thinking people are
going to have to figure out
what do we create that is new that is
fact based
and you can be look some of my best
friends are liberals you can be a
liberal and not be an insane
right just like you can be a
conservative and and not be
super crazy far right but at a certain
point
the grown-ups are gonna have to take
control of the conversation here and and
that's what i'm trying to do and i know
that's what you have been doing
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell